- If you're going to make something,
it's part of a story...
that started before you
came in contact with the materials,
and will continue long after.
- Jonathan's autism made me
think why I'm building this house.
He taught me responsibility.
- I was investing in my block.
I was investing in my life.
- There is an alternative way to live.
- We are trying to use 3D printing
to show that homelessness
is a solvable problem.
- And now we're in the business
of community building.
We're here to change things.
We're here to
make things different.
- There's probably a good reason why
they've always made a door like that,
why that's usually the way it is.
But... what if it wasn't?
- Some individuals,
instead of asking "Why?",
ask, "Why not?"
- If you can build
castles out of grass,
what else can you do?
- Home's built out of recycled
materials...
will be contributing
rather than taking.
- I don't know
if I can change the world...
but I know I can change my world.
- One of the unexpected byproducts
of believing in my neighborhood
is that it's allowed me
to feel safe, free...
and home.